what do you think is going to happen
with Russia and Ukraine in your opinion
so it'll be so I'm a 180 to this guy
um I think I'm a big believer in Putin I
love Russia I've been there on many
occasions uh Putin's a strong and
fantastic leader on the international
stage people seem to think ukrainians
are angels they are off their minds they
are mostly Nazis and the Russians are
doing a good job zielinski is a puppet
uh he was an actor before you may have
clips of him in rubber in high heels
maybe let's play them to the nuclear
boffin and he's being used as a puppet
and installed to create a situation
where Biden gets to animate the new sort
of the industrial complex and uh
personally I think it's the biggest fast
we ever did see imagining Americans are
at all interested in Ukraine is Bonkers
most Americans couldn't find Ukraine on
a map respectfully and nor should they
have to so that's my point of view and
of course it's the opposite to CNN most
lefties and indeed people who live in my
Road in England who adopted Ukrainian
refugees because they're such good
people now if that's the case why why
are we being sold by the media of him
being a modern day Churchill him being a
modern day you know incredible leader
who shows up wearing regular khaki you
know military clothes and people have
bought into this house they're going out
to want to take pictures introduce
themselves you're my hero you're this
you're that why is why does the average
person fully disagree with you on your
position because
um mostly people aren't that intelligent
80 of people have to be introduced to
themselves in the mirror and have to be
taught how to tie a shoelace
um also I think um have to be taught how
to use velcro you know that sort of
thing but also look he's an actor it is
perfect for the job put him in a green
t-shirt always have him sitting down
because he's only five foot four and you
know that I don't agree with short
people so you don't get that sort of
perspective you go to have a photo with
them and you're like you realize you
have to kneel down down this is not the
good guy this is not the savior of
mankind that is being dressed up to be
you don't think he is I it's not that I
don't think he is it's implausible that
this is the savior of anything so so
when I was in Iran and and the Shah that
eventually was in Exile they sold him
the same way to say this is not a good
leader he's not doing good for Iran he's
a puppet to the West right the phrase
puppet to the West has been used many
times are you saying he are you saying
zelinski is it because shot ended up not
being a puppet to the West no Sean ended
up being a person that actually did a
lot more good for that country ever
since that happened we saw what's going
on with Iran so some people may say well
you're saying that because your position
is different but yes you know he's
standing up look their militaries not
the you know Russia's losing so many
people that are leaving their country
Putin just all of a sudden as 300 000
people that are civilians to one or sir
who don't want to serve it's the
complete opposite in Russia and then
some say well you know Putin currently
has an 83 approval rating from its
people but who was really polling so
again going back and forth and that's so
tiring isn't it it's so tiring to try
and find the truth of anything what we
can say is we're just going to load of
CNN reporters stood on the skyline in
Ukraine reporting on absolutely nothing
other than the fact they stood on the
skyline we have uh Putin's people who
still have him with a massive popularity
rating and this idea that he's much
weakened I think is a myth and a
fabrication either he's about to launch
nuclear Armageddon or he's much weakened
make your mind up which one is it and
this has always been a power play for
NATO Putin always had a red line which
he would not have NATO NATO on his
doorstep and that's what was pushed via
solensky is to push NATO onto his
doorstep he was always very clear this
was a red line and he's acting exactly
in accordance with the way that he said
he would if NATO pushed the way to to
his doorstep do you think it's likely
that we go into nuclear war with this or
no no I think it's 100 false I think
it's very much like the covid narrative
people just are hungry for fear and
they're hungry to be told what to do
people enjoy a state of fear because
people are subservient people aren't
bold like they used to be people want to
be told what to do by an even bigger
government you know and my view is the
opposite to that we have to stand up
rise up uh be strong and and not back
down to any of this stuff not back down
to any of this stuff so okay so your
position is no we're not going to go
into a nuclear war that's going to be
all right it's not going to be crazy how
do you think this thing ends do you
think it ends with uh oh a Biden setting
up a peace treaty meeting for them to
sit down and figure out what to do with
different parts of the land do you think
it ends with Putin getting what he wants
to think it doesn't end for a long time
what do you think happens to this it
definitely doesn't have anything to do
with Biden and him negotiating anything
most popular president of all time he
couldn't negotiate his own way of a
bathroom cubicle and we know that
without Jill on hand to drag him out of
there it probably ends if if uh Reds win
the midterms we stop fueling a wall that
America has no place in and Putin takes
over the bits of Ukraine that he wants
to take back and Ukraine backs down but
the only way that happens is if America
stops funding this ridiculous war that
Putin doesn't want to be in so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]